Massachusetts senator Elizabeth Warren
wants to get rid of the electoral
college Warren made that comment last
night during a town hall meeting in
Mississippi much view is that every vote
matters is that we can have national
voting and that means get rid of the
electoral college
well supporters of the electoral college
use some of that same argument saying it
keeps candidates from focusing solely on
major population centers where large
clusters of voters live like New York
and California
speaking of big changes Democrats are
also coming around to the idea of
lowering the voting age to 16 senior
political correspondent Mike Emanuel
tells us why there's a push on the left
to allow younger kids to vote in the
next presidential election House
Democrats tried to shift the voting age
in federal elections from 18 to 16 their
argument is young people are mobilizing
and pushing older Americans to action on
issues ranging from gun violence to
climate change they're at the forefront
of social and legislative movements and
have earned inclusion in our democracy
beginning at the age of 16 Presley's
amendment failed by 179 votes but a
majority of Democrats favored it the
amendment is not adopted
and so does the House speaker who says
she's always favored lowering the voting
age it's really important to capture
kids when they're in high school when
they're interested in all of this when
they're learning about government to be
able to vote Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell fire back there is no
need to drive turnout what is the
problem we had we had the biggest
election turnout since 1966 last year
if the idea here is to make it more
likely we have a higher turnout it seems
to me that's happening and other
Republicans countered Democrats are
pushing it because they're convinced it
would benefit them
think more of those individuals are
going to vote Democrats they think it
helps them just like they think allowing
non-citizens would help them it's all
designed to benefit Democrats and help
them help them on Election Day but a Fox
News contributor and former DNC chair
says it does not hurt to try
16 year old 17 year olds are ready
they're engaged they want to get
involved they want to have their voices
heard I think it's a great idea the
voting age was lowered to 18 back in
1971 but it took a constitutional
amendment and part of the pitch was if
you were old enough to fight in the
Vietnam War
you're old enough to vote at this point
there does not appear to be that kind of
energy to lower to 16